[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
talk a conversation if you will about
your life your money we are taking calls
all afternoon give us a call the number
is free although George these days all
calls are free triple eight eight two
five five two two five joined by the
parsimonious George camel did you
migrate that or is that just in the
Rolodex that's in the Rolodex I like
that word because it means frugal
it's a very expensive word for someone
who's Frugal okay it's that much yeah
it's kind of like an oxymoron but I like
yes love it alright guys give us a call
like I said call in we're gonna talk
about your life your money and George
let's just go straight to these phone
lines okay I'm here for it we got
Tabitha in Atlanta GA what's going on
Tabitha
hi there
um first of all I am very excited that I
even get to speak with you guys
um so um I have several questions
um
um basically okay so I'm a I'm I'm
recovering I'm a recovering addict so
I'm speaking I'm sorry I'm a little
nervous that's okay we're doing great
Tabitha we're here for you we're with
you we're gonna hold your hand and get
you through this
awesome
I now work as a certified peer
specialist and a case manager for the
um Georgia adult drug court
um so this is what's going on I am
um never I was born in poverty and
basically my parents were addicts
themselves so I was never taught any of
these things until I just recently
we started watching these YouTube videos
and it's like a light bulb in my head I
have a I have a career I do not have any
college education
um I'm living from check to check I live
in a um a home for women and children
and so I'm a single mother and I live in
a homework I only pay 30 of my income a
month so I pay 700 in rent okay a month
for where I'm staying um I'm but I am I
living from check to check I owe four
thousand dollars to Aspen Dental because
without education in the research I just
ran to the first place to get my teeth
fixed okay
um so the only debt I have is the forty
five hundred dollars I'm 39 years old
um
and I want to be successful and I want
to be successful with my money and I
want to break the chain of property for
me and my son so he can have a great
life and I don't know where to begin
well first of all you're already
breaking that chain six years clean the
fact that you're diving in you're
looking at YouTube videos you're calling
into the show you are breaking that
chain I know I speak for myself and
George when I say we are so proud of you
um thank you very very I'm inspired by
our story already and when we talk about
changing your family tree this is it and
I cannot think of a more noble and
strong why than the one that you have
today and that's what gives me hope that
you are going to get to where you want
to get financially and we can definitely
help you get there
so what's your income what's your income
looking like
okay so my annual income is um 34 000.
and how much do you see every month in
your check
so every month of my check um one two
thousand uh two three I see about uh
2300 okay
2300 and you've got your rent going out
and then you've got this Dental uh
situation you said you're a single mom
how many kids do you have
I have one one child how old
he is six years old I'm very very cool
he's going on 36. wow so that really was
your why six years old six years clean
very very cool
okay so what are your other expenses do
you have fixed expenses where you're
renting right now because I'm I'm seeing
there's 1600 bucks left you still got to
put food on the table you got to cover
some other bills so you're saying I'm
paycheck to paycheck what do you think
is the cause of that right now
right here and I started
I started and everything like that when
I say I was never really taught
how to money is a tool that you use it's
not to just spin spin and when I was
going to Macy's to to catch up with the
Joneses I was seeing perfumes high heels
outfits I decorated my my apartment
because I thought this is what you do
you decorate and you make everything
look great
so you're saying that you were just kind
of spinning like crazy and I'm guessing
that you're ready to stop doing that
okay so what I would do and we're gonna
set you up with every dollar are you
already on every dollar
um no okay so every dollar is our
budgeting platform here at Ramsay it is
the best and easiest budgeting tool
that's out there and I can say that from
personal experience we're going to set
you up with that
um don't get off the call until you get
that from our phone screener and um more
than that I also want you to sign up for
a webinar that I'm hosting next week on
budgeting we're going to walk through
all of that together it's free so we'll
also make sure you have the information
for that and in the meantime like like
George said you've got this great margin
here obviously I'd like to see even more
margin is there something that you can
do to increase your income
CA would be amazing if I could go get a
second job
um the only problem I have with that is
finding someone to watch my little boy
at night
luckily I have
um you know school during the day I work
the nine to five hours so it works out
perfectly
um but that would be
well there's no child care provided
through your housing right now
oh no okay absolutely not it's like it's
definitely Independent Living yeah with
your skill set could you get another job
that would pay more in the same kind of
field or same role
okay and that that's what the school is
for
um the school well writing that I don't
have no schooling right now oh okay okay
sorry when you said you were at school
during the day my mind kind of went in a
different direction so my son is at
school during the day so that's why
these hours they fit perfectly but um
I'm also in a
second job
um I
happen yeah so you're you're A1 and A2
here are we're getting on a budget which
is we're listing out those expenses you
know what you've got to pay for right
the 700 in rent food utilities
Transportation all of those four walls
you've got to do
um and then anything extra if you have
extra we're hitting it at this debt and
in the meantime we're looking on
opportunities to get your income up long
term and in the meantime even some
short-term uh opportunities to get that
income up how does that sound
sounds amazing you're amazing it sounds
so it's like it's it's like a light bulb
that has been over my head for the past
week and a half I've been walking around
like some of my friends think I'm crazy
and everything I'm like I've got a plan
now come on man you know it's a good
sign if people are making fun of your
financial plan you're going in the right
direction I know that's right you are
going to inspire so many people people
who have been where you've been people
who want to be where you're going to be
and I can't wait for you to call back
and share your debt-free store you're
gonna be there in no time 4 500 bucks
feels like a mountain right now you're
gonna look back at that when you have a
fully funded emergency fund no debt
saving for the future going I did that
yes ma'am hey hang on the line don't
forget we got every dollar for you we
got my webinar for you and hey make sure
she goes through Financial Peace
University as well this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw give us a call
the number is simple triple eight eight
two five five two two five but before we
go to the phone lines my host George
Campbell and I have to talk about
something so exciting that's going on
John deloney Dr John deloney Ramsay's
very own has a brand new book coming out
uh it's the pre-sale has actually
already begun and it's been going like
hotcakes I mean people are just it's
like they've been waiting with baited
breath for this exact book and this time
oh yeah and and the world needs it let
me tell you we all need it this book is
called building a non-anxious life I
feel like it was written for me yes have
you started reading it yet uh they
haven't given me a copy yet I got one
got one I saw it on your desk yeah so I
might steal it if you work at Ramsay you
got like a a pre I don't know Advanced
reader's copy oh thank you George that's
what it's called I was about to call it
like a I don't know what I was gonna
call it but we got one I started reading
it last night love it John let me tell
you something about Dr John the way he
talks about mental health it just hits
different yeah it's just it's not like
not stuffy it's not heavy it's somehow
light but also you're like gut Punch
Yeah it's not like a bunch of jargon and
studies and even I can understand it and
and that's saying something yeah we're
saying a lot but if you go ahead and
pre-order today you'll get 75 dollars in
free bonus items and these bonus items
are pretty legit you get a you get to
see uh one of his latest talks that he
did I actually saw the talk it's
incredible just for that I mean she paid
20 bucks and get the talk and then
you're getting the book for free at that
point that's how I see it that's right
it's worth it you get the audiobook
version of it which in my mind look you
need to read with your eyeballs and your
brain but go back and listen to it too
because there's something about hearing
it in the author's voice that's like I
like John's voice too it's comforting
it's got kind of like a Batman tone to
it you know he's got that kind of
guttural oh yeah okay I'm Batman Okay
more of a Lego Batman Viber which which
Batman Michael Keaton ah you know I'm
more of a Christian Bale guy I'm gonna
be honest dark very The Dark Knight okay
that was the best one I'm with that but
in this book we digress in this book Dr
John deloney talks about six daily
choices that you can make in order to
actually build a non-anxious life it's
not like this thing in the clouds he
actually brings it down and there is a
framework that you can follow similar to
the baby steps and I like me a good
framework George Campbell so absolutely
pre-order today you can do that at
ramseysolutions.com all right let's go
to Kansas City Missouri and talk to
Justin what's going on Justin
going on thanks for taking my call
you're very welcome
I had a few questions about
so I'm in the market for a house uh but
I never owned I'm 45 years old so I'm an
ancient stone I'm sick of dealing with
apartment complexes
um I make 52 000 a year
uh but I have student loans twenty
thousand dollars in debt with that
that's my only debt I own my car no
credit card debt very good I'm bringing
about I bring in about
14.50 a month you know so 2 900 that's
after the pension I work for the city so
the pension
and then I do another little retirement
of 401b and then you know insurance so
that's what I take home about 14.50 a
check 2900 a month so the issue is here
Kansas City's like becoming like
Nashville everything is just shooting up
and I'm people are telling me you need
to buy now you're going to miss the boat
and then I have people telling me the
market is you know which I do believe it
so Kansas City should not be the price
that is I'm sorry it's a great City but
it's not on the coast it's not Chicago
sure but it is the reality I mean the
reality is it is more expensive to buy a
home right now I mean that it the
struggle is real and it kind of sucks
but that is the reality we have to
accept that what I will say though is
the time to buy a house is not when
other people tell you it's not when the
market is just right the time to buy a
house is when you can afford to buy a
house and so let's look at it through
that framework and let's kind of walk
through these numbers here
um
so you've explained that each month
you're taking home 2 900. now this 403
this 401b is that voluntary are you able
to get out of that
that's voluntary yes because we have a
pension where I am so that's supposed to
be like an add-on to our pension when we
retired yeah how much a month goes to
that
I pay a month a hundred dollars a month
fifty dollars a check okay
so what I would do the way we that we
teach it here through the framework of
the baby steps is I would suggest that
you pay off your student loans and get
completely debt free first before you do
okay any type of home purchase and then
after that I want you to save up for a
really good down payment so do you have
any money saved yet I I have only about
three grand say but I do want to add and
I I didn't tell you this I am a veteran
and I was going through the veterans
they have pre-approved me for way over
than I could even afford but they said
you don't really need they just want
earnest money and they said maybe the
closing cost yeah but here's the problem
with with the VA loans I yeah I love
that we're like let's help the veterans
but then the way we help them is by
letting them get into a house while
they're broke with no equity right and
it ends up hurting them long term
because they become house poor they
can't afford other financial goals and
so the VA loan can be an okay deal if
the funding fee is weighed a waived
based on your disability rating but I
still would want you to have a good down
payment and you're probably still better
off going with a conventional fixed rate
loan
I'm new I just got into my job uh post
coven and there is the next step up for
me would be 90 grand now that can be I
could get that at Christmas time or I
could get it in seven years or I may
never get it so you just I don't want to
base it off so I don't know what I'm
gonna base it up you want to base it off
I mean obviously yes your income is
going to continue to go up but here and
now we want to base our home payment off
of our current you know income it would
be one thing if you're like hey next
month I'm starting a new job and I'll be
making 90 grand that's a little
different but right now since you don't
know when that's going to happen we're
looking for something where the payments
no more than 25 of your take-home pay so
you can run kind of run those numbers
back and as a matter of fact we've got a
great calculator
um at ramseysolutions.com how much home
can I afford and you can type that in
and use that calculator and it's going
to help you see okay here's what I need
to save like this is the amount of the
purchase and then you can run that back
and say okay how much do I need to save
to put a good down payment it would be
amazing if you could put 20 down and
then you can avoid some of the fees that
are associated with it but get as close
to 20 as you can
I agree and you know because you don't
want to be trapped like my rent is only
900 I know it will go up that's right
I'm looking at mortgages
1600 and you're right I would be house
broke yeah and that's not going to be a
blessing I know people are telling you
get a house get a house you'll never be
able to get a house they don't pay your
bills Justin you got to pay the bills
and when you barely can put food on the
table and cover insurance and cover no
other goals and then one emergency hits
and you got no money yeah while having
student loan debt you're going to be
calling us back saying I gotta into a
house before I should have what do I do
and I don't want to see you there
especially veterans I've got such a
heart for veterans thank you for your
service and sacrifice thank you and I I
believe that you can do this in a
peaceful Financial way but it might be
five years from now instead of a year
from that's right and it might not be
the home that you're envisioning like I
don't know what you have in your mind
but yeah you got to remember like this
thing George it's a ladder and sometimes
you start with a condo and then you go
to a townhouse and then you go to a
small single family and then you like
don't think that you necessarily have to
start out without Justin
pardon are you single
I'm divorced yeah okay I'm divorced so
it's just you we don't need to go get a
four bedroom in Kansas City just to have
some different real I don't see many
rooms in my house I'm in the kitchen I'm
in the living room and I'm sleeping I'm
still wondering why I have a dining room
I don't know why that
reset your expectations get out of the
student loan debt uh the baby step one
thousand Buck emergency fund you have
that so you're at baby step two and so
the key here is let's get our income up
and knock out this 20 000 student loans
let's get the emergency fund in place
three to six months of expenses then
let's start tackling the down payment
and you might need to move we might need
to go hey I got to get out of Kansas
City it's too expensive right that's
right right and the the student loan I
could put more down on it like a treat
it like a car payment right you know
this would go down especially if you
pause investing you're doing 17 things
at once and they're all good things but
we've got to have some Focus intensity
right now and that is where the baby
steps work every time you work them
that's right we're putting any and all
extra money that we can find scrounge up
dig up work up we're putting that on the
student loans and we're going to pay
them off with intensity as quickly and
as possible that's how this whole thing
works that's how you get out of debt
that's how you pay off your student
loans I don't care who you are whether
you're Justin or somebody listening out
there pay off your student loans do do
it with intensity this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show Jade
warshaw your host today joined by George
camel with an amazing YouTube show by
the way oh thank you yes the George
Campbell show you are not paid to say
that no but I appreciate that you know
it wasn't one of your obligatory hey
Jade you got us talk about this that's
right so thank you I just looked at your
wonderful face George and I thought this
guy's got a wonderful YouTube you let me
be on one of your episodes that's right
we were it'll be out very soon we did a
really fun interview with Jade that you
gotta tune into so go you can go
subscribe youtube.com George camel and
we got three episodes a week I mean the
team is crushing it it's hard to take
credit as you know because the team is
doing so much work to get this stuff out
the door and we're having a blast doing
it but dude the amount of people who are
subscribing to to that page because it's
so good you got to feel sometimes we
were like I want to become the first
Ramsay YouTuber yeah you know not a show
that happens to be like we are making it
for YouTube and we're having a blast
totally totally different from all the
other wonderful offerings that we have
here but this is totally different and
that's right a lot of uh Millennial
memes and snark and yeah Quick Cuts it I
mean it is you it's like squirrel brain
it is I love it
love it it's great check it out in the
meantime uh George something really
funny came through you know we're always
here reacting to articles different
things that pop up that we think are
going to be relatable to you and this is
one George from The Wall Street Journal
yeah this shocked me here's what they
said 50 or 500 when do we tell our
partner what we've spent and it goes on
to say cap on purchases reduces conflict
and preserves Financial autonomy in a
relationship and I'm like let's go Wall
Street Journal like they're talking
about this stuff and they got it right
for once yeah and so this is something
that we've taught for years and that is
often misunderstood yes because people
say Jay do you want me to combine bank
accounts I'm gonna lose all autonomy I'm
gonna lose who I am as a person yeah and
I'm going by combining bank accounts it
doesn't mean you don't get to spend
money it just means that you talk about
it first right exactly yeah exactly and
even in the framework of even budgeting
sometimes it's like this idea of if I
budget I won't get to spend my money
anymore or I won't get to do these
things and it's like no it's it's all of
this together we're budgeting we're
talking with our spouse and we have line
items on there for personal spending yes
right it's not this like don't tread on
me jade you can have your own line item
it can be Jade's fun money and Sam's
fund that's right and it is and you set
the limits for both they made my wife's
fun money is more than mine yeah because
she deserves the Finer Things in life
and I'm like it hurts for me to spend
money okay I got several line items on
the budget that say Jade next to it
there we go it's hair it's Nails yeah so
it's not about this like well you got to
spend 50 so but if there is a cap say
hey if you're gonna spend more than a
hundred bucks we gotta talk about it
first yeah well you know especially if
you've kind of got like a like a slush
fund or like a miscellaneous category
that's just like hey this one this money
right here is a little bit up for grabs
that especially you need to talk to
because if you've got line items on your
budget let's just say I've got a hundred
dollars of fun money
I you know correct me if I'm wrong
George but I'm like I get to spend that
hundred dollars and as long as I'm not
doing anything illegal yes I don't
really have to tell you what I just did
now if you ask me if I come home and
Sam's like hey what did you do I'm like
oh I went to Target you know blah blah
blah but then if there's that kind of
Fund in the middle that's like 200
miscellaneous I don't think it's fair
for someone to just go and up and spin
that without saying first hey that 200 I
saw a lamp at TJ Maxx I was thinking
about getting it you know what I mean
yes and so the key here is communicating
up front and don't blame the budget
blame your lack of communication the
budget didn't do anything wrong because
you're the boss of the budget until it's
done then the budget is the boss of you
so have the conversation with your
spouse and say all right we're agreeing
Jade gets a hundred Sam gets a hundred
and you can do what you want with that
yeah and we're gonna talk about it but
this idea that you need this autonomy
with money is just an excuse for
financial infidelity for selfishness for
immaturity and you don't lose that
because you're married and by the way
you lose autonomy just by getting
married and John deloney had a great
clip on this yeah well you don't you
lose your sense of Personality or
identity yeah but it's not all about
what you want to do anymore that's true
there's another person involved yeah
conversation because
you'll have your autonomy I mean you
still have your freedom you still have
your freedom but it's a more matured
view of Freedom it's teamwork now yeah
it's it's you're free to make choices
but those choices are with your husband
you're still free to be able to do the
things that you did before but you
understand how your actions affect the
other person like there's still I don't
feel like you like get confined in this
way it's just like okay like we're
learning about each other this is what I
like to do but you're open about it
you're talking about it and uh I'm
Curious George
whoa Curious George I'm curious
about gosh
um you and Whitney oh yeah so is there a
number that it's like hey if you spin
this don't come home having spent this
and not talk to me because it's gonna be
fireworks oh well there's there's
categories like groceries if Whitney
goes and spends 100 bucks on groceries
and it's in the budget I'm not like whoa
you spent over 100 bucks it's those
things that are outside of the normal
household necessity categories like we
just bought a tapestry for Decor that
she's been wanting a long time a
tapestry I know I didn't even know these
words existed and it's from anthropology
which if you know anthropology
everything there is like a bajillion
dollars and so that's right we talked
about it she was like Hey I'm gonna buy
this tapestry I've put it in the budget
I've been wanting this for a long time
it finally is here it's on sale yeah
it's 150 bucks and I was like cool glad
we talked about that versus it being a
big surprise it's like whoa where did
this come from yeah and then we're not
having a fight about it so if you've got
a spouse that's constantly you're up
against and it's a battle again it's not
the budget's fault there's something
going on deeper there I'm and it could
be Financial trauma it could be control
issues yes control everyone grew up
differently yeah control issues will get
you quick if you grew up in a
controlling household and then your
spouse just asks us you know makes that
simple request of hey let me know you
when you spin and you start getting
triggered and you start getting a
conversation grenade you just threw in
there so but you got to get to the root
of what's really going on and the joint
account again not the problem it's you
it's not an ish me it's an issue yes
that's right and figure it out can I
also call out George because some people
will be like yeah me and my husband we
combined our finances and really what
they're talking about is they have an
account that doesn't show an account
it's a joint account that they put a
little of their money into and he puts a
little of his money into and that's what
they're calling from my financial
roommates with privileges okay I don't
subscribe to that I saw the Steve Harvey
videos like everyone should have four
bank accounts yeah his account her
account the joint account the savings
account I'm like let's just simplify our
life y'all life's already 2 too
complicated yeah let's have our joint
account and a savings account let's also
joint and let's have full awareness and
accountability of what's going on and
I'm telling you that's what caused my
wife and I to win with money so quickly
it expedites it you see exponential
progress when you both are aligned and
have visibility that's right and yeah
and there's trust there you're not going
to go far very fast if there's not trust
and part of that is like hey like you
said total visibility he sees what's
going on I see what's going on it's all
good good discussion all right let's
take a quick officially reach like
feudal feudal medieval Lord status
having a tapestry that's pretty big a
tapestry I think I still don't know what
a tapestry is it's part of your middle
my parents do love we had furniture at
the camel household that was made of
glass
I I'm telling it was the most uncut it
looks very Royal looked like we had some
like Thrones going it was Game of
Thrones in my house growing up but you
sit down and you're just like you are
the sphynx cat just but it looks fancy
glass Furniture the arms are glass oh
the cushion is rock hard see what I know
it's totally flat
interesting I know about putting plastic
on the furniture do you know we did that
growing up yeah gosh that's when you're
really deep in you're trying to preserve
everything you never want to buy
anything ever again if you put if you
put plastic on your furniture that's you
saying I'm never spending money ever
again I mean is it is it art are we just
supposed to appreciate it underneath the
plastic it's supposed to preserve it
like if you buy a nice couch you put the
plastic on it then nothing gets on it
this wasn't my my aunt and uncle did
this it was only when like you had
people over you take off the plastic and
you sit and have the Turkish coffee and
the desserts and it's you know but other
than that it's like a museum like
package that thing back up that's right
so there's you got to have limit guys
you can't take it to the extreme don't
take it too far there's three things
that you can do with your money give
save it spend it and if you're gonna
spend it make sure you talk with your
spouse make sure you put these
parameters on it make sure you're having
open conversations don't be out here
trying to control somebody but have a
conversation yeah this is Planet Fitness
this is a judgment free zone okay let's
just be adults let's talk about it let's
make a plan and then we said we stuck to
the plan then we're not the villains
listen the plan's the bad guy okay give
it a name if you want call them Kevin I
don't care it's Kevin's fault classic
Kevin Behavior
the point is if you don't like what's in
your budget you get to change it the
budget should reflect your needs and
your wants this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw today joined by
George camel give us a call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five we'll chop it up we'll talk
about your life your money whatever's
going on in your financial situation we
are here to offer a little bit of help a
little bit of guidance we're not going
to tell you exactly what to do you can
do what you want to do but we will give
you some great advice and what we would
do honestly that's all we're going to
tell you yeah if we were in your shoes
here's what we would do we answer as
honestly as we can while steering you
toward a better financial future that's
right and but at the end of the day
George I will want to listen to you
because you went from
debt to baby step millionaire yeah in a
very very short period of time I'll be
honest it was aggressive and people go
like you went from broke to millionaire
in 10 years you must have had this crazy
income I'm like no I just had a wife who
was on board so dual income for sure
helps and we were so all in on the
Ramsey plan that we were like we call
themselves the test tube babies yes
because we just did this thing and so it
might take you 15 20 years I'm just here
to tell you I'm an average guy I didn't
grow up with money and here I am and I
got some and I'm still living very
frugally like my life didn't change I
you think when you hit millionaire
status like you're gonna be balling I'm
like my life really hasn't it's still
the same George in there you go with you
yeah that's right and I mean my habits
have stuck with me yeah I'm still
couponing me and Sharon Ramsey out here
still couponing right it's not like
you're tapping into your 401k every day
and your home equity right so life is I
still got goals there we go let's take a
call from Anna in Denver Colorado what's
going on Anna
okay
um I bought a car about a year ago I'm
also I'm also a nurse but I bought the
car for about thirty two thousand
dollars that's there for 2020
um Edge
um but anyways I also have about twenty
thousand dollars worth of school loans
um and then I do have like 22 000 in
savings
um so I was just kind of wondering I
mean
I am also a single mom so I do you know
would love a nice reliable car sure um I
did look at potentially selling my
vehicle and
um I don't know if it's just when I
bought it or what but now it's
um like Kelley Blue Book says it's only
worth about like 18 to 20
000.0 on it
I'm sorry what do you owe on the car
um 28 000. okay 28.
so you're about 10 grand underwater in
this thing if Kelly Blue Book Is Right
was that private party
um yeah so I've I've gotten offers for
like twenty thousand which is yeah about
what it's saying but
um yeah it's like to buy a new car old
new car you know it would be probably
around three to five grand so what's
your income and that's like it
um I make about 80 000 a year okay
how much are you bringing home every
month
um around four to five grand
and what's the payment on this car
um it's 500 23 or something yeah
okay so we have 18 in car loan and 20K
is that one student loan are they broken
out into multiple
um they're broken up into multiple great
so what's your smallest student loan
balance
uh four thousand okay so we can knock
that one out pretty quick in fact we can
do it today because we have a lot of
money in savings don't we
to where we can knock out the student
loans completely today that would free
up a whole lot of payments wouldn't it
yes and how great would that feel going
into October knowing that you don't have
to make it you're watching the headlines
everyone's freaking out and you're like
oh yeah that thing's just amazing that
thing is gone how does that feel Sally
May don't live here no more
that would feel good but yeah I mean at
the same time though I was like is it
worth selling that caught like that
would be a big you know to get rid of
that twenty eight thousand dollars the
car is not really the problem in your
life I mean based on your income the car
is reasonable yeah you know should you
have done it no but now that we're here
we're 10 grand underwater you make 80
grand the car is not worth more than
half your income it's your only vehicle
right
yes okay so I'm just gonna go we're
paying off for student loans today now
we're attacking the car and making 80
grand how quickly could you pay off 18
with without those student loan payments
in your life
yeah pretty quick is it 18 or 28
oh it's 28 28. so 28 grand in the car
loan so we have that left making 80. and
so I would say within a year I would
think so can you live on 60
probably then there you go there it is
can you work extra overtime
I probably I mean I don't love to but
I'm a nurse so it's out there yes yeah I
mean it's out there if you're a nurse I
feel like one of the best things you can
do is work that overtime and be that one
back I'll take that shift I'll take that
shift and you do that for six months and
you're gonna be like oh I never have to
do that again picture this picture this
Christmas time rolls around
you don't have a debt in the world
you've paid off your car you've paid off
your student loans you've started
stacking up just because you've worked
extra so we're you've moved quickly and
you've started stacking up some savings
maybe you've got five or six thousand
stacked up you're going into Christmas
you're buying presents and the whole
thing is so peaceful you didn't have to
get caught up in the student loan drama
or you know or in the fall back in
October and September and you're going
into a new year completely debt free
you're having savings set aside and you
have completely changed your financial
Outlook how would that feel
amazing you don't have to work overtime
anymore
come on now
right absolutely so the key here is one
thing at a time Anna I know it feels
overwhelming right now you got a whole
bunch of debts I mean single mom you're
working your tail off and this is a
season and you're gonna look back and
you're still gonna say I would do that
all over again to have the financial
Freedom piece that I have right now and
the way I set up my kid because of what
I did during that time was so worth it
and so I know it feels like oh gosh I
knew they were going to make me go to
work
but that's the plan there's no shortcuts
here that's right Anna are you set up
with every dollar that's our budgeting
tool
um I don't okay today I want you to log
on everydollar.com and by the way uh we
have a promo going on you can log on to
every dollar slash George and get
yourself 15 off and use that okay you
get a year for 15 off or if you're like
Jade I'm not trying to spend any money
you can just go to every dollar and do a
free trial and just do the the free
version not the premium version you log
your own transactions and all that but
it's good especially as you're getting
started for you to actually have to pay
attention to all that instead of
automating it especially when I was
starting bursting it was helpful for me
to have to look in that Financial mirror
in that bank account and go like oh bro
what'd you spend on eating out this week
we got to do better next week I agree I
agree so get set up with every dollar
when I tell you it's going to change
everything it's going to change
everything and when I tell you it's
going to provide so much motivation
because of the tools that are inside of
there there's so much learning inside of
there there are so many things that will
help you project if I do this where will
I be financially and when I tell you
it's gonna just light a fire and inside
of you you are going to do this so
quickly it's going to make your head
spin
okay all right all right Anna thanks for
the call oh that's what I'm talking
about George so her question which debt
should I pay off first the smallest one
the smallest one why is that well
shouldn't you be looking at the interest
rate I mean that's really the thing
listen this isn't about math we wouldn't
be in debt if we could do math okay
basic math addition and subtraction and
so this is something I had to do I
pulled my credit report to figure out
what debt do I even owe because I didn't
know at the time when I graduated
college and when I saw those numbers it
was overwhelming but then I made a list
the smallest to largest and now all I
had to do was focus on that little one
that's right you don't have to look at
the rest of them yeah it's like all
right two grand I could do that I could
not I could knock out two grand instead
of looking at the huge number which all
had over 460 Grand if you just looked at
a huge number and went all right we got
to pay off 460 Grand never that instead
it's we got to pay off two grand now we
got to pay off three grand all right
next one's five well you already did two
and three yeah we know it's possible now
yeah I'll be honest we listed them we
listed the debt smallest to largest we
did not add them up you know what I'm
saying like we didn't add them all up to
see what does it equal that didn't come
till later we just focused on
palpitations on that I would have been
like oh I mean I saw your list of debts
it looked like the Star Wars credits it
just kept rolling I was like shame
goodness gracious Capital went on that
was on there like 12 times that's I
didn't know you could legally have that
many student loans and credit cards open
at once I'm like what are lenders
thinking giving people more money okay
it shouldn't be legal but they do it I
can't believe these fools were loaning
US money because we were only making
thirty thousand it's not like we had
this job you're always so happy when
they give you the debt they're never
happy when they go to collect it and
you're not paying it it's funny how that
works I know that's right so free
yourself
that's what it comes down to from the
hand of the hunter as the Bible says
that's right deliver yourself deliver
yourself like a gazelle from the hand of
the hunter that's what you got to do you
gotta move with intensity and you can do
it that does it for this hour of the
show George it was a nice hosting next
to you good time uh we'll see you real
soon because we got another hour coming
up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your money
I am your host Jade warshaw joined by
George camel the illustrious
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two two eight eight two five
five two two five there it is they're
all tongue twister it really kind of is
actually it's not I just messed it up
thanks for being real jade you're such a
real one you know I try to just keep it
real with the people give us a call
we'll take your call talk about your
life and money and we're gonna do that
with Jeffrey he's in Charleston West
Virginia what's going on Jeffrey
hi guys thanks for taking my call no
problem what's going on
I guess just kind of feeling overwhelmed
I recently started listening to you guys
and um just looking at our our debt and
honestly just uh probably scared
um
I I'm a pastor and then I'm also a
chaplain so I work two jobs there and
then I also have another job
um and uh I have my wife and I we have
around 12 000 in credit cards
um and I have just under 80 000 in
student loans
and then
then of course we have our house as well
but um I guess I'm just uh is it the
student loans where to get started is it
the student loans coming back that's got
you
feeling sometimes
and so maybe I'm crazy too but I'm I'm
currently finishing my Master's Degree
right now which I've cash flowed
um great the whole time so you haven't
so all of those loans are from my
bachelor's degree which was crazy and I
wish somebody would have told me that to
begin with
um but um but I should have that
finished up next year but yeah I'm
starting to look at it saying I will
have to pay these back and um and just
realizing we're like one catastrophe
away from not knowing what to do well
what do you have in savings
um about twelve hundred dollars okay
okay and is your wife working outside
the home
no and uh she has a lot of health issues
and um so like we can pretty well Bank
on after our insurance we will pay you
know six thousand dollars up front to
meet our catastrophic cap every year so
she's not actually able to work oh my
goodness yes we just know that's coming
up again in January as well and uh you
guys have kids
two okay and is there are they older are
they in school their child care
they're getting ready to be teenagers
and my wife home schools them okay um
but I'm also looking ahead to them going
to college and realizing we don't have a
whole lot of time and I uh I do not want
them to take out student loans yeah can
I ask um
this might sound some type this might
sound strong but I'm it's just a
question
um I've got two kids they're three and
five and they're a handful
um staying I used to stay at home with
them and I also used to work from home I
wonder you said your wife's got health
issues but she's homeschooling kids and
taking care of them that's such a big
job and it requires so much energy and
so much work it makes me wonder if there
is something that she could do
to earn money that might honestly be a
little bit less work on her physically
does that make sense
yes am I way off base by even suggesting
that
she definitely could not work a typical
job
um just with I mean literally
appointments almost every day there's a
lot of chronic health issues okay and uh
and so like I will chip into the
homeschooling as well as my in-laws will
help out with the home screen I see so
it's kind of a team effort okay I just
wanted to check and float that out there
in the most respectful way possible
we're just digging to find some options
for you to help you climb out of this
thing so what is the household income
um so after taxes and insurance
everything I bring home uh right around
5200 a month okay good that's good and
we've got 92 000 of debts staring us
down
so have you started following the Ramsay
baby steps and looking at the debt
snowball and listing them out and seeing
kind of what your timeline looks like to
get rid of this debt
um I've started listing some of this out
um I haven't really
I honestly when I started listening out
it just it's overwhelming it became
overwhelming and overwhelming I feel
that um years back before my husband and
I got out of debt I'm just going to tell
you a quick little story time I went to
I had remembered hearing about Dave
Ramsey and I went to pick up the book
The Total Money Makeover because I
thought this will help us and of course
in the book they tell you to start
listing your debt listing your income
and I was so excited getting the book
but by the time I'd actually done all of
the things listing our income listing
our debt I felt just like
I'm never gonna get out of this because
you see that reality staring you in the
face but I promise you if you keep going
and keep doing the things that the plan
says that will start to turn around
because you're going to see something
that you can do today no matter how
small and then you're going to see
something that you can do tomorrow no
matter how small and those little things
that you do are going to start to add up
to a big impact and you are going to
look back on this and this debt is going
to be gone it might take three years it
might take five years it took my husband
a nice seven and a half years
um Jeffrey to make this happen and so I
know that the same can happen for you
and you'll probably do it much quicker
because we had four hundred and sixty
thousand dollars of debt
so I hope that gives you a little bit of
Hope in this moment
um if I'm you my my A1 is I'm getting on
a budget are you using a budget yet
um I just came up with a budget in Excel
spreadsheets the other day okay good and
when you do that budget how much margin
is left
to throw out debt
above the minimum payments
um
I'm not looking at it right now but
probably
um
probably at least I would say at least a
thousand but I think I could probably
squeeze more out of that okay awesome
that's very that's good now what's your
mortgage payment every month
uh one thousand twenty dollars all right
so you're good there that's reasonable
comparatively to your income I'm trying
to figure out if there's anything that's
just crushing the budget right now but
the fact that you've got a thousand
bucks to throw extra gives me some hope
here because that's at least 12 Grand a
year right so we start just doing the
math we're like all right the credit
cards are gonna take a while yeah credit
cards are gone a year are you going to
get an increase in income from this
Masters
um maybe at my chaplain job what was the
purpose of getting it
um I just kind of always wanted to have
that and was trying to set myself up for
the future
um and then I ended up a few years into
it and realized I only have a couple
classes left and yeah so I'm just I
don't want to not finish it at this
point yeah yeah I think this is gonna
I'm only gonna keep it real with you
this is going to require a deep level of
sacrifice and this is probably going to
require working like you've never worked
before and that's all that's all I can
tell you you are going to pay this debt
off and it is not going to be without
sacrifice and that's kind of that
mindset that you have to have going
through this you're going to sacrifice
to win you're going to work more hours
than you've ever wanted to work you're
going to cut your budget leaner than
you've ever wanted to do it but you can
do that and it will be so worth it when
you're on the other side of this in the
meantime I want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com student loans get
some information there about what's
going on with your student loans get
some hope there and if you're interested
in every dollar we've got that on the
line for you so don't go away after this
call our phone screen will pick up for
you
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
show where we take calls every day
basically Monday through Friday George
and we help people with the hardest
things that they're facing not just
financially we find a lot of times that
when there's issues with money it starts
penetrating into many other areas in
their life personal real quick and it
starts touching relationships and
emotions and career and past mistakes
and baggage and family boundaries or
lack thereof and man money's just all
tied up in that it's all tied up in that
and we love helping people sort that out
so if you want to talk with us give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we will
do just that George something very
exciting is going on we do this every
once in a while and it is our cash
giveaway oh I love giving away Dave
Ramsey's money because you know he's not
hurting he's no
we can bless some people and we get to
be a part of that I call that a win I
know that is a win-win we're giving away
uh your chance weekly guys we're giving
away 500 every single week and then at
the end there's a grand prize of 3
hours you can do a little bit that's a
little bag our chances of winning this
way better than the Powerball so yeah
you won't be a billionaire no but people
actually win this stuff they win it and
I think sometimes people are like oh
I'll never win so they don't enter but
real people win this money look you can
enter every single day and then like I
said they draw a winner every week you
get 500 bucks and then if you get to the
end and they draw your name you would
get three thousand dollars okay that's
ramseysolutions.com cash giveaway and
sorry just giveaway looks like oh yes
giveaway slash giveaway that's right
they're easy on them we're like less
typing yeah that's right what was I
talking about and while you're over
there um you can also get best-selling
books like The Total Money Makeover
um some Classics like paycheck from
paycheck to purpose and one of my
favorites on your pass change your
future and those books are on sale guys
on the low low 12
um while you're at it you can go on
ahead and re uh pre-order Dr John
deloney's new book coming out uh
building a non-anxious life that is a
must if you don't do nothing else make
sure you go over there and pre-order
that book today if you do so you'll end
up with 75 dollars in free bonus items
money making scheme Jade come on now if
it's free it's for you and me I'll take
some of that too
um also you can go on there there's
those questions for humans cards if you
do not have a deck of questions for
humans cards you're missing out they're
so great they're so fun friends family
couples there's all sorts of different
additions there they're on sale for 12
right now as well at ramsesolutions.com
store is where you would find that so be
sure to check out those two spots
ramseysolutions.com giveaway to get the
cash and then ramseysolutions.com store
to get this stuff that's on sale all
right
George what we got
well I've been seeing this trend and
it's it's entertaining to say the least
and it can be bothersome but my wife
related to it when she saw it and it's
called girl dinner girl dinner and there
is a money tie here although you may not
think so and so let me explain girl
dinner because I had to wrap my brain
around it because it's just videos of
girls saying hey I'm eating a piece of
salami and cheese and a cracker girl
dinner and I was like what is happening
yes George you you explain girl dinner
for the people I had to look this up
like this is from a CBS News article
this catchphrase was first used to
describe a no cooking required
collection of items like bread cheese
fruit and other odds and ends for dinner
okay so it's basically when you're like
I don't feel like cooking I'm just gonna
kind of snack and call that a dinner I'm
with that it's like foraging exactly now
dietitians are obviously upset here
because like women are under feeding
themselves like they need to have a more
sustaining meal there needs to be more
nutrients and nutrition so I get if
you're living a lifestyle where it's
just girl dinner every night that could
be that could be bad I feel like girl
dinner could be a well-balanced meal
because and correct me if I'm wrong if I
go in the refrigerator I open it up I
kind of like this idea well at least
what I've seen of it because at the Crux
of it is they're just eating what they
have at the house exactly they're not
going out and going you know I could
really go for a Chef Boyardee they're
just eating what they already have so
it's like you open up the fridge what do
I find in there a piece of salami well
not in my fridge but okay a piece of
cheese I go in the cabinet there's a
couple of Ritz crackers I don't know
what you're eating these days there's a
jackfruit in there you know maybe
there's one pickle left go ahead and eat
that one pickle don't let it go to the
waist like I like that idea and if you
put enough things on your plate you'll
get full and there's probably some
protein there's probably some good carbs
on there that's true that's fair so
George I've seen my wife do this where
she's like yeah I'm like hey what do you
want to do for dinner she's like uh I'm
fine I'm like I gotta eat and she's like
oh I gotta eat I had a girl dinner I had
some snacks I'm like well I guess that
makes one of us no you're a great dinner
at all right I need my hungry man frozen
meal I gotta eat I have big bones and
they need to eat and here's the thing
like I get so much joy George from
finishing an item of food that I bought
like when you have a jar of pickles and
you finish it
you know what I mean it doesn't go bad
you actually finish a jar or like I just
or there's leftovers in there and it's
like you've been eating spaghetti for
four days and you just go on ahead and
finish it like that gives me a feeling
of like all right I've done something
really good here with my life such an
overachiever Jade I'm the kind I go to
Trader Joe's I'm I am aspirationally
buying a bag of kale knowing full well
and good that I'm gonna throw this bag
of kale away unopened in five days no I
think that there is something at the
core of this that we can all take away
financially which is it's really easy on
the weekend right it's Saturday that's
when a lot of folks do their grocery
shopping and it's like okay it's
Saturday that's that is like automatic
it's time for me to go to the store but
there's probably food at the house that
you can eat and like mama always said
there's food at home there's food at
home my thing is like don't do not go to
the grocery store and start buying a
bunch of food until you do inventory of
what you already have you might be able
to make a girl dinner or something a
little bit better with what you already
have you know what I'm saying so I I
kind of like the idea there I think
there's a video of James do you guys can
we play one of these videos they're
overly the crew's been waiting with
baited breath Let's Play videos to give
these people an idea
this is my meal I call this girl dinner
girl dinner
[Applause]
oh wow that was okay so if you were
watching on YouTube you're lucky because
that was a wine glass filled with mac
and cheese with a chicken tender hanging
off that should have been a kid dinner
that's a kid dinner
that's not
look those chicken nuggets were in the
shape of dinosaurs so that's what I
would call a kid dinner
I that's not what I was thinking about
I'm thinking about like there was a lot
going on there visually and then just
audibly it was jarring it was a I was
like I have sensory issues after hearing
that now when I think of a girl dinner
I'm thinking charcuterie like this is
just crackers if you're gonna do that
you want to try this at home this
weekend you at least one protein so meat
hard-boiled eggs cheese maybe chicken
salad some smoked salmon something
colorful some fruits and veggies for
some Fiber and then something fun they
say crackers olives pickles can add some
flavor and then lastly make sure it's a
proper helping you know this is
charcuterie why are they acting like
this is New Look No George Let's Tell
these people our idea because our idea
is better which is you just go in the
refrigerator and what you have you eat
you don't have to go out and check those
boxes because then what's the point you
don't have to go check the people the
way they grocery shop it would be like
you getting in your car and then just
driving around aimlessly wasting gas and
then wondering why you didn't get
anywhere you got to have a destination
that's why meal plan is having a list
avoid the end caps the floor is lava
let's get out of there in and out nobody
saw it that's right that's how it should
be with grocery shopping instead of just
willy-nilly choosing random things that
look interesting and then you get home
and you realize I didn't get any food
that's right and let me add one layer
deeper because this is my favorite thing
folks are always like Jade how do you
not go over your grocery budget I'm like
I just bring the cash I take the plastic
out of the wallet you all know I don't
have credit cards but I take my debit
card I don't bring it if I'm trying to
really do right I put the cash in the
envelope George and that's the only
thing I'm bringing and do you want to
know what you can't do when you only
have the right amount of cash
buy more than you bargained for come on
and you want to know what you are going
to have to unless you bring a calculator
you're going to have to embrace the fact
that when it hits 200 if that's all the
cash you have and they go ahead and scan
that box of Keebler elves and it puts
you four dollars over do you want to
know what you have to say can you take
can you take that one off
that's why you go to the self-checkout
and then you don't have to say the
shameful words you just take it off your
darn self and it's all good there's one
blessing of self-checkout that's right I
gotta figure out where the little
barcode is on a lime I'm stressing out I
can't handle that you gotta start
memorizing those numbers four zero one
one that's the number for bananas it'll
always be locked in my brain I can't
remember my own cell phone number at
this point Jade
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
everybody you are listening to the
Ramsey Show I'm your host Jade warshaw I
am joined by George camel co-host and
today guys thank you so much for giving
us calls man for calling in trusting us
with your deepest darkest money
situations that is an honor we do not
take lightly so thank you for doing that
continue to call in and we will continue
to help you as best as we can George it
is hard to believe but it is back to
school season can you believe it what is
going on with the South when I grew up
it was like after Labor Day we're going
back to school in the Northeast thank
you in school already in the first week
of August I'm shook I took my son today
he's gonna be a kindergartner took him
to do his placement test today and I was
like I can't believe school is starting
already I saw the kids in my
neighborhood with the little like
chalkboard you know first day of school
I'm like this is precious we didn't have
that growing up Jade no we didn't it's a
modern luxury with the letter boards it
really is but that time of year is here
and teachers and students across the
country are heading back to that
classroom and uh to honor the heroes
that we call teachers George we have one
of our incredible foundations in
personal finance that's the curriculum
here at Ramsey but we've got a teacher
here on the show with us today who is a
teacher of Foundations and personal
finance it's Eunice and he's with us all
the way from Chowchilla California so
let's talk to him what's going on Eunice
thanks for being with us today
hey guys hey guys so uh so happy to be
with you George I feel like I know you
I've seen you in my course daily oh on
the on the TV screen I appreciate that
that's right because George is you're
teaching I hosted the curriculum so they
see me every single video and then I
also do some teaching and I love getting
messages from students that are going
through it and they're like dude you're
the guy from the you know you remember
watching videos in school growing up
yeah and so I feel like a minor z-list
celebrity you're like the guy from
Reading Rainbow just like that I'm
nowhere near levarberg but hey it's such
an honor to have you and you're a hero
to us and you've how long have you been
teaching foundations now
uh two years two years
um originally the idea I pitched it
before covet and my school was on board
but then we know what happens right
that's right especially California
manual deal yeah wow so how many
students you have enrolled in your in
your curriculum now how many are you
teaching
this year I'm actually going to have
more so it's going to be four uh five
periods and on average is 30 students
per period oh wow and they're all
seniors so really it's the whole senior
class that's incredible well and it's
getting real for them now they're
actually thinking about like oh gosh I'm
working I got money I got bills to pay I
got College coming up I want to upgrade
the car I got to pay for my own
insurance so they're leaning into
everything
they are I've taught many courses as all
everybody knows in my school but this is
probably the first time I'm teaching a
course where every student is
100 engaged because like you said it is
their life they know they can apply
everything they learned the moment they
step out of the classroom I love that
and they're like man I'm so glad I'm
learning this instead of calculus and
you know when the war they hit the War
of 1812 you have to use this in your
everyday life absolutely and I heard
Eunice that you do this crazy activity
with the students uh about learning how
to pay cash for cars and all kinds of
stuff what is this activity you run them
through
so I I see the course I like the content
but how can I make that even closer to
my students and and ciao is a very small
town so so access to outside information
is is very valuable to us and all that
so I do this activity where I
I tell students to make a five to eight
minute video
uh and it can be a multitude of areas
but one of those is to go out to a
dealership or a furniture store or
whatever it is that usually has a uh
something to purchase that you can
actually apply for a loan to get and ask
some hard questions so they go out there
with with uh you know some of them come
up with questions that surprise me when
I see the video later but yeah going to
a dealership that is incredible uh they
ask questions they say wait you can sell
me that car and they'll most excited yes
we can I love that so you're like you
guys are gonna get out here you guys are
going to get hands-on experience they're
learning about the traps
one particular student that asked they
kept digging he kept saying wait so
you're telling me if a family comes here
and they can't afford that car
what would you tell them well if they're
looking for that car they probably need
that card it's like no what if they
don't need that sports car so he kept
asking these questions and and all the
students were so curious to what the
answers are going to be and obviously
the the outcome here is if you want
something in today's day and age you can
get it but are you going to be owning it
or you're going to be just borrowing it
until you can't afford it and then you
have to return it and feel even worse
than you started that's right the
borrower is slave to the lender man
Eunice thanks for hanging out with us we
love what you're doing you are changing
lives by teaching this curriculum again
the curriculum is foundations and
personal finance and if you're
interested in learning more about that
or how you can bring it to your school
or home school you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
education thank you again Eunice for
chatting with us that's what I'm talking
about can you imagine if Eunice was our
teacher in high school I mean my life
would be so different come on now it
would have changed everything I read a
stat George that said 70 seven percent
of adults said they did not feel
prepared for personal finance when they
became adults coming out of school 23
who did they went through our
foundations and personal finance
curriculum okay because now it's been
out long enough that we're meeting
adults who are like oh yeah I went
through that in high school yeah that
Ramsey stuff man that changes everything
that's right it was a need and we met
the need let's take some calls let's go
to Alex she is in Austin Texas what's
going on Alex
are you with us Alex there she is
here thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
I have a question about how to handle
debt that has gone to collection a
little backstory is last year I had a
tumor removal surgery and I took some
bad advice from a family member and
um the advice was to basically Let It Go
to collection before you begin to pay
but now it has gone to collection and
all the alarms in my body are going off
and I just want this gone and out of my
life
and I was wondering if you guys had any
advice on how to approach the situation
I've never been in any debt before and
my goal is just to get it paid off as
soon as possible how much debt is it
Alex
it's about five thousand dollars total
okay
um is that the original bill
uh yes okay are there any fees that have
been added on
not that I know of okay so that's
exactly what you owe how old is this
debt
it's been it went to collection a month
ago okay so collections paid a tiny
amount for that debt and so if it's just
a month old they may not be willing to
negotiate with you or settle but I would
still try and I would ask for an
itemized Bill and make sure that what is
on that bill is exactly what you
actually had done have you done that yet
I have I reached out
um I had heard an old video of something
similar so I asked for a receipt upon
arrival and I got a few of them back
from different collectors because
they're all in different locations and
and so some people responded and the
interesting thing that
um that I notice is that some of those
debts are still active on the hospital
website yeah so I wasn't sure if it was
better to pay directly to the hospital
even though it had already been sold to
a collection agency if it's already been
sold you you're dealing with the
collections agency now I bet you if you
were to call the hospital they would say
hey we have record of it but we're no
longer
um collecting the payment on it
how here's where I'm at like you said
your body is telling you I owe somebody
money you're feeling the anxiety of this
you're feeling the stress of it how
quickly could you just pay this off
I could I could um reasonably call them
this week and have it done
so why are we not why are you not doing
that you have the money to pay for it
today
yes do you feel like you're being
scammed in some way or that this
shouldn't cost this do you feel like you
were overcharged or mischarged because
if if if this is what you owe I'm gonna
go in there today and I'm gonna pay this
bad boy off that's what I would do and
get everything in writing I'm done with
this thing you you owe what you owe and
it sucks and we're not going to do it
again but just call and make sure you
get it in writing and say hey this is
paid in full I'm done with you guys once
I pay this amount do not give them
access to your checking account that's
right that's such a good word George
especially if you do call and you do
make some sort of deal get that in
writing forever keep it in a folder
never get rid of it but I would just not
even fool with it and pay that bad boy
off don't lose any more sleepover
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show give us a call
we'll take it triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number and
we've got Mir in Chicago Illinois what's
going on mirror
hey guys how are you guys doing doing
good how are you
good I'm doing good thank you for having
me
how can we help today
yeah so um about seven years ago I filed
bankruptcy chapter seven because I had a
lot of credit card debt totaling about
like 50 000 just in my name my wife had
another like 3 000 I paid that off but
seven years ago I just it was just bad
decisions on my credit card and I just
filed bankruptcy because I I thought I
had no other option and that ended last
year
so we were finally able to buy a house
that we just bought a house about two
months ago
and my credit card debt is back up it's
just bad decisions again so my wife
because since I already filed bankruptcy
I was only able like I wasn't able to
get approved for a lot of credit cards
but I right now I have about 16 000 in
my credit card debt
and my wife has about 22 000. oh my
goodness and yeah and we're just in like
a really bad position right now
um I'm I think I'm going to get laid off
from my job and I think in December
because that's what the company is like
that's what they're sounding like
they're going to lay everybody off in
December they're just shutting down what
kind of company is it
it's a it's a cult solo let's say
hearing aid company I just work in the
warehouse in the factory so you know
this layoff is coming have you started
looking for other jobs
uh not yet
but I am going to start like this month
and next month but
so we just yeah so like I was saying we
bought a house and that is about 220
000. okay we have mortgage left 420 000.
what's the mortgage what do you pay
every month
about around 1900 so two thousand
dollars almost okay
cars do you have car payments or
anything like that
no all of all of my cars were paid off I
paid those off as fast as I can okay no
student loans nothing like that
no nothing okay hey what's going on with
these credit cards why why are you back
down the same road that led to
bankruptcy what's going on there
this bad decisions it was like being
refinisher for the house just everything
I prayed across because we don't have
cash
what are you earning household income
combined you and your wife
uh my life doesn't work but so last year
we got a proof of our house because I
was making around fifty thousand dollars
a year fifty right since the company
yeah fifty thousand dollars last year
but
since like the company is like shutting
down and like they're slowly removing
lots of employees this year on
projectors can make around thirty five
thousand okay but you're also getting
another job We're Not Gonna if you're
we're not waiting around until December
to see what yeah and your income is
already starting to go down why isn't
your wife working
she's just she's old she used to work as
a nurse but what do you mean she's old
how old is she
55. that's old she's not old
she's not old and she's broke y'all are
broke she's gonna be working till she's
75 at this point if you don't change
something hold on question does she does
she have money are you guys combining
your finances
no she doesn't make any money
do you guys have anything in Savings
Credit Card yeah
is there anything in savings
no all right I'm um
I um
am holding back a little bit of re of
frustration with you here your wife's
gotta work that's number one number two
you've gotta get Mo you gotta get moving
my guy there you're heading down you're
literally looking at the map from your
bankruptcy and you're taking that same
path now and you this is your wake-up
call to get off of it you guys gotta get
on a budget you've got fifty thousand
dollars of income your wife's gonna go
out she's gonna get a job I don't care
what it is she's getting something in
the next couple of weeks and that is
going to lead to the next something
that's what she really wants to do but
no matter what she's got to get income
coming in you've got to get your income
up with this next job and you guys have
gotta get a clue turn into the adults
that you are and stop buying things you
can't afford it's that simple you guys
are out here just spending and spending
and buying furniture and going to dinner
and trying to keep up a lifestyle that's
not yours dude and at what cost it's not
worth it who cares how nice of a couch
you have
you're feeling this pain of debt you've
already walked through bankruptcy is it
worth it
okay it's not worth it mayor you called
today because I feel like you're on the
brink of ready to change but you're not
quite there yet and so if you really
want to change you've got to have anger
towards your situation and right now
you're just kind of like I might get
laid off my wife's not worried she's
just too old and we'll figure it out but
man I really don't like having this debt
you're going to be headed toward another
bankruptcy soon if nothing changes
You're Gonna Lose the house if nothing
you're not gonna have a house to put a
couch in because they're going to take
away that house in foreclosure when you
lose your job or you're making 35 Grand
and can't pay your 2 000 a month
mortgage so it's time to cut up the
cards are you ready
yeah you're like a recovering alcoholic
who has the fridge stocked with alcohol
and then you're wondering why you can't
make traction we've got to remove the
Temptation and ability to spend more
than we make yeah is your wife how does
your wife feel about this is she like
hey it's time to change have you guys
had this conversation or is this you
kind of you know poking around online
and finding the Ramsay show tell me more
about that
so my son actually told me about the
Ramsey Show and I thought I might just
give it a call see what advice I can get
yeah she's very frustrated with me too
because
she doesn't earn any money it's just her
credit card that I'm spending all the
expenses on and she doesn't want her
credit report to go bad who cares about
the freaking credit report yeah you guys
are y'all are focused on the wrong way
beyond that my man credit your credit
score your credit cards all that talk
all that mentality is out the window
from now on we buy things in cash right
we buy things that we can afford A1 step
one today is you guys getting on a
budget that's that's Numero Uno you can
start that tonight that's a good thing
about a budget George you don't have to
it's not something that's in the future
do that tonight A2 is we're starting to
look for jobs for both of you like we're
getting that train going we're not
waiting around is there a reason that
your wife is not worth it working aside
from the fact that you guys are elderly
AIDS behold
no she used to work as a nurse and she
got like really arthritis in her knees
she can't she can't walk that much she
can't stand is she on disability
no she can get a desk job I mean we sit
all day I sit too much
could she work in a hospital setting
sitting down in a different position
can she do teledoc nursing
there's look there's options we can
split hairs about what she there are
options out there what I'm concerned is
I think you guys are cutting yourselves
out I think you're counting yourselves
out and you're so busy trying to use
credit cards that you're not giving
yourself credit that you actually have
the ability to go out there you guys are
smart you can earn money you guys have
the ability to control your finances you
do not need credit cards to do the
things that you want to do on an
everyday basis it turns out George you
can actually buy a couch in cash you
know what I'm saying so I think for you
guys this is just digging deep and
getting to the root of why you're why
it's the why because something tells me
right now I can tell you about budgets
all day I can tell you about the debt
snowball all day but until you get to
the root of why you are the way that you
are the famous words of Michael Scott
why are you the way you are you're gonna
keep doing this this is going to be an
endless cycle and so for you I really
want you to dig deep on this sit down
with your wife really have that come to
Jesus moment of like look we gotta
change we got to do something different
or else we're going to file bankruptcy
again please don't do this and mayor
we're going to help you out on top of
giving you one year of every dollar I'm
gonna give to you guys one year of
Financial Peace University watch all
nine lessons do the budget do all the
steps we teach in that before you go
make another dumb decision and cut up
the cards today it's done and you gotta
get on board otherwise you guys are
gonna be right back where you were seven
years ago and I'm more Angry than you
are at this point that's a problem it is
a problem hang on the line we'll get you
guys the help that you need gotta get
that mind right it's imperative to get
your money mind right that does it for
this hour of the show you're listening
to the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions and broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
money
this is where we build actual amazing
relationships as well I love it I'm your
host Jade warshaw joined by George camel
about to be
a dad yeah
oh my gosh Jade thanks for the reminder
I know it's potential crisis yeah this
is baby month so uh baby month pray for
us you're doing good you're you're
you're here you're you're focused well
the dads are kind of like useless up
until you know other than just
supporting mom the whole time and then
babies here and then it's I'm ready
that's right I gotta change some diapies
so get at them while you still can the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm still sleeping
somewhat well yes tap into this delicate
genius genius sitting right next to me
so delicate so ever so delicate like I
said the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we will
get into it we got Mark in Denver
Colorado what's going on Mark
hi good afternoon so honor to speak with
you you too what's going on actually I'm
actually not in Denver Colorado I'm
actually close to Gary Indiana I'm an
over the road truck driver all truckers
cool campaign markdown um
uh I gotta uh I got a question
what is your opinion or your thoughts on
the current trend of the micro houses
um
I'm looking at I'm working the steps uh
I'm in step two hanging off that uh I
went through a divorce last year I
basically haven't had a place of my own
now in almost two years
uh when I am ready to buy a place
it's just going to be me by myself I'm
single no kids no nothing so I'm
wondering
if these if a micro home depending on
property it's on or whatnot you think
it's going to be an appreciating asset
in the long run the other thing is when
I'm thinking about buying a home is
since I'm gone for four to six weeks at
a time
I really don't think a regular home
would be good for me even a small one
because I'm not going to be able to mow
the grass I'm not going to be able to
shovel the snow I'm not going to be able
to take care of it and I thought that
might be good for me would be buying a
condo or a town home there you go and
that's kind of where I'm at I love how
you're thinking about this I love how
you're trying to choose the right option
for you and your life your work that
makes sense
um it seems like George might go a
little further into the tiny house I
have a lot of thoughts my I'll tell you
my initial thought is this is kind of
this is relatively new in the culture I
would say it's not something that's been
around for decades and decades and
decades and decades
um and so I would prefer to invest in a
market that's a little bit more we know
that it's a little bit more stable a lot
more stable really so yeah you're you're
probably not going to be the guy that's
got this four bedroom house on Bunches
of acres of land but I do think that
there's a situation
um that is right for you whether it's a
condo a townhouse where you are invested
in something that we know is going to go
up in value over time and again yes when
you have a home it does serve that
purpose of that that purpose of hey this
is a place I go to lay my head I you
know you have the lawn mowing in that
side but there's also this thing where
it is a wealth building tool and it's
such a huge part of building your wealth
over time and so and of course it's
keeping your your biggest monthly line
items stable right we don't want you
renting forever because rent just goes
up and it's always fluctuating and
changing so that's kind of the argument
I have
my concern about renting is I don't know
if it would be worth it for me to rent a
place for the time being because like I
said we started the divorce proceedings
in March two years ago
uh my wife had covered real bad she was
in hospital I had a month off and then
after that things just kind of fell
apart um but so it's been since
Christmas two years ago before I've
actually had my own place where have you
been staying just certainly
I've been staying and using a friend's
address in Colorado okay uh typically
when I go home you know like I said I
usually work four to six weeks a month
and a half at a time I'll go home for
like a week I'll take a week off and
I'll spend one or two nights with my
brother and his family okay and the rest
of the time I'll usually find an
inexpensive hotel that's been three four
or four or five nights and then I go
back to work yeah so you're just yeah
okay
and I don't know if
rent renters Market housing market in
Colorado is just unreal right now yeah
and I you know a studio a small
one-bedroom apartments 1500 bucks a
month yeah and when I go home I'm only
spending six seven eight hundred dollars
every six weeks on a hotel room I think
for you it's like cost benefit analysis
it doesn't fit me but the other thing is
is you know working for a month month
and a half at a time in a semi truck
you're in your truck I basically live in
this thing and a lot of truckers do we
basically live in our trucks I mean
you've got the options you've got in
front of you are you're in baby step two
so even if you wanted to buy a home
right now I would say let's get out of
debt first so that's that kind of
shelves and tables that and if if you
decide I'll be out of debt by February
or March of next year excellent that's
great and then you can kind of start
saving up and see what happens next but
in the meantime you know what you're
talking about my husband and I used to
work in entertainment for cruise lines
and we would travel like 52 or like 35
weeks out of the year so there was this
thing of like we're never home and so we
got the cheapest town home that we could
find which happened to be one that his
mom was renting out and then we got
roommates
to cut that in half so it was like okay
now this is more like it we're paying
like 600 bucks a month we're only there
sometimes so I think you can get
creative and find the right situation
where it's like okay I'm not overpaying
but I'm also not getting into something
that's too expensive for my purposes
yeah I don't think a tiny house micro
house is the right move for a whole lot
of reasons number one you need the land
that it sits on which is expensive you
need all kinds of permits you need to
build the thing and it's way more
expensive than you think and it
appreciates in value because there's
just not demand for it even if it's not
if it's on a foundation it still won't
increase much in value because they're
just simply not much demand so I don't
want you sinking all this money into
this thing and then all of a sudden
you're like I don't even want to live
here anyways so for a lot of reasons
don't do it I actually did a whole video
on this exact topic on tiny homes on my
YouTube channel called the only way to
afford a home question mark where I dive
into this for about nine minutes in
detail so go watch that for my full
answer the solution I think for you is
my friend in Chattanooga rents out a
room in his house to a guy who does like
he's kind of travel nursing so he's
there like one week out of the month and
he runs to him cheaply in the other room
yeah and it's a great situation so I
would either find a situation like that
or just keep doing the hotel thing I
mean your life as a vagrant is just wild
right now so it doesn't make sense to
plant roots until you have the money to
where you can afford to take the hit of
just paying that small mortgage payment
every month on a condo just so you have
somewhere to lay your head you can call
your own yeah and again that's kind of
what that's kind of the thing that what
I was thinking is I'm just gonna have to
bite the bullet and work through like a
year from now
to be able to finish paying off my dad
hopefully by the end of the year and
then one last thing I should be all done
by February or March and then you know I
have no expenses yeah other than that's
a blessing so let's build a small
emergency fund on the road that's why
I'm I'm aggressively attacking my debt
right now that's right and you're doing
the right thing you're aggressively
attacking the debt like you said it's
going to be gone by next year March
April you're going to build up that
savings and then you can start looking
at building up savings for a condo and
again it's not just to have a place to
lay your head it's because you're
stabilizing that biggest line item on
your budget which is housing and
eventually you'll be able to use that to
build some wealth this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show uh I'm Jade
warshaw this is George camel hey if
you're a new listener and you want to
dive deeper into the Ramsay baby steps
what am I talking about you hear us all
the time callers call in and we're
giving them advice based off of just a
format a set of principles a plan that
we have here it's based on seven baby
steps and that's what we're talking
about if you're like Jade y'all are
saying things I don't know what it is
head over to ramsaysolutions.com and
click on that get started button there
will help you figure out your best next
step for your particular Financial
Journey based on exactly where you're at
today and you'll get all that lingo
explained hopefully you'll be inspired
by it and you'll have to you'll like
start doing it that's what we hope for
you but that's ramseysolutions.com and
click the get started but button that's
the thing George we talk about a lot of
things that's you know we use
terminology and some lingo that's like
what are you saying gazelle intense what
what inside baseball yeah but once you
hear like oh that makes sense it's all
common sense we don't try to use ten
dollar words for fun we put the cookies
not even on the bottom shelf on the
floor I know that's right because money
is already complicated and stressful
yeah we don't need to be talking you
know like I'm a guy with with suits on
yeah with all my accounting jargon yeah
back in the day that was nothing that
that was the thing that led me in is I
was like okay this is this is for the
commoner yeah that's why Dave is so
successful he brought personal finance
to the masses and went you don't have to
be a financial expert and have a degree
yeah I don't want to help you figure
this out I don't want anybody to make me
feel silly about my questions all right
so the Ramsay show question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from trusted locally owned
businesses like Mr Appliance Mr Handyman
and Precision garage door service I need
that visit neighborly.com today to find
home experts available to serve you
today's question comes from Holly in
Utah she says I'm 23 and I'm a recent
college grad I'm currently working
making 50 000 a year and I graduated
without debt and currently have twenty
thousand dollars in savings my monthly
rent is 700 bucks a month and my car is
paid for my question is how should I be
investing my money at this stage of my
life
way to go Holly I'm impressed excellent
I was waiting for there to be like a
giant conundrum here I know waiting for
them to have but she's got no debt she's
got the emergency fund making 50k at 23.
we are ready to invest that's for sure
so how does she do that well the
simplest way here's the my five word
investing strategy is you just go okay
if I can remember this I got it match
beats Roth Beast traditional and so you
just use that filter
to go okay do I have a retirement plan
through my employer that's a great place
to go generally a lot of employers have
a match so it might be hey we have a
three percent match which means if you
put in three percent they're gonna put
in three percent that is a 100 return on
your investment so we take that first
then be on the match we're gonna look at
all of our Roth options so generally a
lot of people uh may have a Roth 401k
that's a great place you can just fill
out the whole 15 thing that's great and
that's baby step four which is where
Holly's at invest 15 of your income into
retirement now a lot of people say I
don't have a Roth 401k well you probably
have access to a Roth IRA which is
outside of an employer a lot of people
get those confused the 401K Ira what's
the difference just remember 401K is
through your employer Ira is outside of
your employer that's very good and so
that's a great place to go next once
you've maxed out your Roth IRA you've
exhausted all the Roth options you can
go back to that tax deferred uh plan
which means Roth is after tax money that
grows tax-free the tax deferred plan is
hey I'm not paying taxes on it now but I
will when I withdraw in retirement yeah
so you Circle back to your traditional
so 701k now it's good to note that these
accounts are just shells yes your 401k
you got to actually buy something inside
of that in order to be investing so we
recommend growth stock mutual funds
spreading that across four different
types to keep them balanced and I've got
a whole video walking people through
this on my YouTube channel called
Investing For Beginners that we uploaded
about a month ago where I walk them
through this because it can get
complicated how do I choose the mutual
funds and what are the four types and
what's all this stuff about
diversification and compound growth you
can feel overwhelming absolutely that's
one of the reasons we suggest working
with a smart investor Pro or somebody
who can walk alongside you and help you
make these choices just educate you
they're not doing it for you yes they're
just showing you the path and you go
okay I know what I want to do yes and
never ever invest in something that you
don't understand if you're like I don't
get it that's okay just wait until you
do get it keep keep educating yourself
keep talking with your smart investor
Pro and don't be afraid to ask questions
look if somebody makes you feel stupid
for the questions you're asking it's
time to move on and find somebody who
will have the heart of a teacher and
teach you hey let's continue this
conversation just a little bit further
so because there's a lot of things that
I thought about when you read that
question of the day
um next question I thought is
a lot of people go okay I I can't invest
in a Roth IRA I make too much money oh
that's a hey great problem to have first
of all so the Roth IRA does have income
limits there's a great little back door
option called the back door Roth IRA
where you essentially fund a traditional
IRA with after-tax dollars and then you
convert it yep
something that's like a takes forever to
do and it's totally legal it is not yeah
it's it's not this like well we found a
loophole in The Matrix no this is
totally legal it's it just sounds sneaky
when they say back door it makes it kind
of sound like wait a minute and then
George let's continue it a step further
because I just this is it gets juicy
yeah let's let's teach a little bit so
then you've got that let's say that
you're just killing it like you you're
maxing out a Roth 401k you're maxing out
an IRA yes where where do we go next
George what's next I think the HSA is
one of the greatest life hacks investing
tools so that's a health savings account
you're going wait what a health savings
account to invest yes you can invest
with a health savings account once you
meet a certain threshold that's right
some of these accounts so ours here at
Ramsay after a thousand bucks I can
begin investing any extra money into the
stock market through mutual funds
through your HSA and you're thinking but
that's not for retirement it's for
health care expenses tell them well once
you turn 65 you can withdraw that money
for things that are not qualified
medical expenses and becomes like a
traditional 401K at that point that's
right so you will have to pay taxes on
that money versus using it for qualified
medical expenses you don't have to pay
taxes so there's still a benefit to use
it for that stuff and at 65 my joints
are going to be aching I'm going to be
dipping into that HSA I know I know
that's right Dave Ramsey has an HSA and
he doesn't actually use the HSA he uses
it to invest and he just cash flows out
of his checking account for any kind of
medical expenses so that's kind of a
life hack yeah I love that hack the way
I do it is I keep the deductible liquid
and then you can keep investing from
there on so in case I don't know if
you're a person who you know you're
going to hit your deductible it's in
there that's kind of a good way to think
of it too now George let's call out the
fact that in order to have an HSA you
have to have a high deductible health
care plan that's right hdhp there you go
and everybody may not have that so
George you know where I'm going next
what if I can't get a HSA George oh this
is exciting where do I go next but if
you have exhausted all tax advantage
retirement options you can always just
open a taxable brokerage account what
does that mean that just means this is
not for retirement this is just for
General investing while I'm in my
working life and that money use after
tax dollars you invest it you'll have to
pay taxes on that capital gains and
there's different structures for that
depending on how long you left the
investment and all that stuff in your
income
but long-term capital gains is your best
bet so if you just leave the money in
there invested for a year you'll have
probably most people 15 is what you'll
pay on the gains so on the appreciation
of that money through compound growth
and that can be a great way for those
that want to do uh the fire kind of
stuff retire early you want to retire at
50 but you can't touch your retirement
funds until 60s good Bridge so for 10
years it becomes that bridge account if
you've got 500 000 in there and you can
live off you know 50 60 70 a year that
can get you to 60 to when you can start
dipping into the other buckets like the
Roth 401k the traditional IRA whatever
it is so there's a lot of options out
there and for a self-employed folks they
always go like I don't invest because I
don't have an employer no no no you have
a solo 401K is an option the SEP IRA is
an option taxable brokerage account HSA
so there's you're not excused from
investing as a matter of fact you're
you're definitely not excused you have
to be more intentional than the average
bird because there's no employer you
know over your head offering this to you
and it's you know you've got to be into
it's not as easy you got to do some leg
work but the nice thing about those
options for self-employed folks is that
contribution limits are higher yes
that's right so I especially with the
solo 401K you can really get into some
some good investing there oh yeah this
is good juicy stuff no one ever wants to
just chat about investing
options because I like that we talk so
much about getting out of debt and
sacrificing to win let's talk about what
it feels like to finally get to take
some of this money for ourselves set it
aside let's learn what those steps are
and enjoy it a little bit don't
overthink it the key here is your
savings rate not how much and did you
choose the right fund you just do it
consistently over time so go check out
that YouTube video investing for
beginners on my channel
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I am your host
Jade warshaw joined by George camel give
us a call the numbers triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we will
talk to you about what's going on in
your life that's what Zach did he's in
Phoenix Arizona what's going on Zach
hi guys how you doing I'm doing good how
are you
doing all right so me and my wife were
on baby step number two and we are
pretty much set to get out of baby step
number two and move on to three probably
about six months way to go however we we
uh we ran into a roadblock my wife
is said to have surgery back surgery
here in a little bit uh we kind of held
that off a little bit I have her uh
getting a second opinion from another
doctor but it's still looking like
she's gonna have to get the surgery okay
the issue I had it's pretty invasive
surgery
um but the issue I have is that she has
a medical issue and every time she's had
surgery
There's issues that stem from that and
she goes out of work for you know
several weeks there was a time where she
first started her job and she's like you
know four months into it and this was
just last year but she's four months
into it and she has to go and leave but
she has no time and so she's leaving
without pay so my issue is I obviously
have prayed that nothing's gonna happen
to her and you know it's going to be
smooth surgery yes but the offset chance
with her medical condition if it does
you know have some issues or
complications with it would it be okay
to cause baby step number two save up
some money just in the case that she has
to stop going to work for
short period of time and then go right
back into it when she's back
you said it absolutely this is what we
would definitely call a storm mode you
have a medical situation that's coming
you know it's coming you know it has the
potential to be costly in in more ways
than one possibly
um I 100 would do that um how much debt
do you have left in the debt snowball
you have 25 000. okay
and um we paid off a total of probably
about 22 000
um we were kind of slow starting and
then I got her pretty much we both sat
down we got on the budget together and
we went gazelle intense pretty much in
April and so we paid off around 22 000
already very good what's the 25 that's
left what does that make up
uh it's a car uh car loan so we just uh
two months ago we just paid off all the
credit cards cool and now it's uh what's
left is the car loan what's what's left
on the so 25 on the car loan what's the
car worth
uh it's work 27 okay the Kelly Blue book
that was a couple months ago so I would
assume it would be right around the same
and what's the income let's say she's
not working what will the income be
gross per year
yeah so her take home per month is oh
the way I do the budget it's not
necessarily per month because we get
paid 26 times every year got it so I but
I I kind of plan just for you know that
extra payment we're just gonna throw to
uh baby step numbers kind of like act
like you live on the 24 payments
exactly yes so uh she takes home every
uh two weeks 3 900.
okay and then all together it's uh 8
500. awesome okay great income I'm just
trying to figure out here
because of your situation and how
quickly you could clean this up if you
just you got a less expensive car and
it's not it sounds like it's not a huge
part of your world I don't think it's
one of these like he got to sell the car
tomorrow what are you guys doing but
because of your tumultuous medical
situation if you sold this car you
walked with two grand how quickly could
you save up the difference to then go
get a car in cash that just gets you
from A to B for a while while you get
this emergency fund stocked up which
would help me sleep better at night if
I'm in your situation
yeah and we we did talk about selling
the car at one point uh but that was
obviously before this uh medical
situation happened so you know not not
on the Dave Ramsey plan we're just
living the American way right and we're
just you know buying car loan car loan
here and everything like that so I got
it for her uh graduation present um oh
this is cinnamon this is emotional now
yes it's a little bit so you know she
was on board she actually said to sell
it and I know that was I know she said
to sell it for with good intentions but
in the back of my mind too it's like hey
you you went through you know Helen back
I really want you to you know
um I think we can pay this off pretty
quick and so now with this and the bump
of the road we haven't had that
conversation since then so maybe that it
would be I think we'll revisit it
because I I know you had a great motive
and pure hard going man she really
deserves this car but what you guys
deserve right now in this season of your
life is Peace and Freedom and levity so
you can focus on her health instead of
how we gonna make this payment and how
is this going to pause our debt snowball
so if I'm in your shoes I'm gonna have a
real hard conversation with my wife and
go hey in the next two months we can
save up this much that will give us
enough if we sell the car we'll have
enough to go get a beater car for five
thousand dollars eight thousand dollars
that will get us from A to B until we
get to solid Financial ground with a
fully funded emergency fund which I
would have six months for you guys for
sure with the health conditions hey
speaking of those health conditions
actually
sorry I was going to say speaking of
your health condition or your wife's
health conditions have you guys hit your
deductible yet for the year or do you
foresee like having to pay thousands of
dollars out
um in order to do so for this surgery
oh no we we had a deductible and I have
pretty good health care for my employer
so so it's more covering the bills if
she doesn't have income than it is the
medical bills
that yeah that would be mainly what it
is is that hey can we get you know we'd
be pretty would be pretty
tied down with losing her income yeah uh
because it's almost half of it at that
point yeah well then I don't want just
something to happen and it just gets
extended and now we're you know now
we're trying to what's that car payment
x uh 550. man Freedom 9.50 tomorrow that
would change my life if I'm in your
shoes yeah and the thing about this
stuff is sometimes we get so
um we get so connected to a purchase
that we made because of settlement
sentimental reasons because at the time
it was a good purchase in our minds but
when you look at it the way that George
said which is look you can have 550
dollars free like that's a lot of money
free you can always get a car again you
know it's kind of like sometimes we
think we can if we sell it we'll never
be able to have it again and it's like
no I bet if you sell it on down the line
you can have a even nicer car
when the time is right so freeing up
that 6600 bucks a year of net income
going towards that payment I know you're
going to pay it off soon but I'm just
looking at the situation going if this
was any other circumstance she had great
health she was going to continue to work
I'd say let's just pay the car off do
the debt snowball but it just is worth
considering to give you guys the peace
as she goes through this surgery and
heals yeah that we don't have a payment
in the world yeah and now we've got the
emergency fund starting to get built up
and I just think sleeping better at
night is better than the sentimentality
of the car I agree I'd want to take the
fastest possible path to get to that
piece like you said because they've
still got to get the they've still got
to clear out the debt
um
they would still have to think about
funding their emergency fund and you
know maybe saving up for a slightly
nicer car you know after selling this
one and I just think that
it feels like a huge sacrifice in the
moment but what are you getting like the
P like you said rarely do people look
back with regret on those decisions and
go man we shouldn't have sold that car I
know here we are debt free and it's just
a worse and I wish I had that nice car
so it's a good reminder though for those
that are wondering do I pause the steps
do I pause it at snowball and the only
two times you do that is in storm mode
and storm mode so if you know there's a
storm coming the layoff's gonna happen
you're gonna get fired whatever it is
there's a baby coming there's a surgery
coming let's pause make minimum payments
and save up as much cash as we can
that's right Georgie made such a good
point and I want to hammer in on it I
can tell you guys in George I know you
have your own stories when you're
getting out of debt the sacrifices that
you're making for some situations more
extreme than others but never once have
I ever looked back and gone man if only
I had just bought that dress or if only
I had just you know been able to get
that steak dinner it would have changed
everything I never I got lambasted
because I had sold some a few Apple
stocks I had from when I worked there to
help finish off my debt snowball people
are like this guy's an idiot does he
know how much money he could have I'm
like you know how much peace I have you
don't even think about it
I'm good bro I'm gonna be okay so do
what it takes you will not regret
following the Ramsay sure won't it'll be
worth every penny
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right you're listening to the Ramsay
show give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
scripture and quote of the day Daniel 12
3 says this those who are wise will
shine like the brightness of the heavens
and those who lead many to righteousness
like the stars forever and ever
Jimi Hendrix said knowledge speaks but
wisdom listens oh okay all right Jimmy I
know Jimmy that's what I'm talking about
Jimmy
um guys I want to take a moment before
we take a call to tell you about
something that's going on we are doing a
series of webinars about budgeting y'all
have been talking to us we are listening
you need help with your budget who
doesn't it's not easy to just go out
here for the first time and start
budgeting there's a lot of learning
curves there George there are a lot of
little things that sneak up that's like
hey what if I don't get paid the same
amount every month well they they
self-select out and go well Jade it's
not for me because here's the thing my
situation is very unique oh everybody's
an exception to the rule I get that
everybody's the exception it's like Jade
I'm a waitress though and
or I don't make enough to budget oh
I'm like bro it's just an intentional
spending plan intentional you sound like
somebody else that I will not say their
name on the radio
um the point is the budget is it's a
tool it's a tool that you use to get
your money right and here's the fact we
know y'all are out here living paycheck
to paycheck the stats are telling us you
guys are telling us by calling into the
show we want to help you we're going to
help you uh I'm kicking off this series
of webinars I'm doing one next week it
is August 9th is that correct yes I want
you to sign up it's totally free okay 12
30 Eastern time 12 that's 11 30 a.m
Central Time look this is the last break
I'm saving my spot that's a lunch break
you can go in there with your Public Sub
or your Subway sandwich it doesn't
matter if you get lettuce in your teeth
no one will see you because it's a
webinar and unless you ask you know you
you can ask questions but you don't have
to put yourself on the camera
so you could just eat your sandwich sit
in your you can pop it in the chat you
can get on audio only so don't be scared
you're not like right on prices right
here it's just Jay she's the star of the
show and if for some reason you're like
hey I signed up for the webinar
something came up I wasn't able to meet
to make it it's recorded so you have a
recording of it so there's really no
reason to not sign up this is what
you've been waiting for we're going to
answer all those questions sign up for
the webinar it's everydollar.com
budgeting did we mention it's free it's
free there's two parts of this that's
free a the webinar where we're teaching
you and B every dollar is free the
budgeting tool when I tell you guys
about every dollar I am not blowing
smoke I've been using this thing since
conception George since it very first
came out back in 2016 2017 it did not
have all the bells and whistles that it
has now now it's got these features
where even if you have irregular income
it's got that paycheck planning where it
helps you see this is when you spend
your money so that you don't run out
because that's the missing step for a
lot of people it's like hey I know I
have the money I budgeted it out but
somehow I'm still like coming up to zero
two at the 15 on the fifth end of the
money right so you have to actually
decide okay I know what I'm gonna spend
but the paycheck planning tool helps you
decide when you're going to spend it
throughout the month so good so many
features guys this is your chance don't
miss it not one day day one let's go all
right George let's take a call we got
Simon and Rockford Illinois what's going
on Simon
hey how are you guys doing good I have
too much energy right now I'm sorry that
I came in hot right here and she got all
riled up over budget man this is how we
roll over here a true nerd what's going
on Simon
uh yeah so um I am uh I'm 20 years old I
still have uh two years left of college
um and basically I'm just trying to
figure out come out of college with the
with the best path made for me to become
a a millionaire at a young age or not
not necessarily millionaire but be
financially free at a young age
um so I have uh roughly 290 000 in
investment
um
well okay so so uh most of it came from
uh uh inheritance about 252
000 is an inheritance
um that's in a traditional IRA uh what I
put in is I have a thirty thousand
dollar one year CD at four point seven
five percent right now and then I also
have eight thousand dollars in uh Roth
IRA wow as well as I have uh twenty
thousand dollars in a savings account
what the heck why are you calling us
dude you gotta be hosting your own show
You're Gonna Be A Millionaire if you do
nothing if you did nothing else yeah if
you leave The Inheritance in that
investment account
you will be a millionaire in no time
right right but you're saying hey hold
on your thing is not to mess it up
that's your thing don't mess it up by
being so
um I I don't know if I can say but so
bent on trying to be a millionaire and
trying to get there faster that you
support us in the hair yeah that you
start investing in in things that you're
finding on Tick Tock and things that
your buddy over here is saying if you
don't if you don't cool out and go hey
this this is pretty nice you can mess
around and lose that money by bad
Investments so George is going to help
you out here yeah so do you have any
debt right
uh no I do not and my I'm uh fortunate
enough for my parents to be paying for
college
um awesome but the the main question I
have is I would love to get into uh real
estate my parents have about 14 units of
their own um I see where it gets them um
but I would love to get into real estate
as well because uh I'm studying physical
education right now
um and as you know uh the starting
salary around where I'm living is it's
about 45
000 and I mean that I I assume I'm gonna
have to budget with that
um I don't know yeah
to pay my own bills and and do all this
I'm just trying to figure out
um you know if I should take this money
from this investment account and put it
into a uh put it into a real estate unit
maybe even live in it like a duplex or a
or a fourplex
um and then generate income off of that
so then on top of my forty five thousand
I'll have right I don't income as well
here's what I would do you got two years
left of college you've got this money
sitting there it's it's parked in the
right place go to college finish that
and then I this is just me George might
tell you something different and that's
his prerogative I personally would not
invest in real estate until I was an
owner of my own personal residence
then I'm able to see hey this is what
this is what ownership looks like this
is what it feels like these are the
types of repairs that I have to do this
is what it costs because you have I'm
not saying this in anything negative at
all but you my friend have been
extremely fortunate you got parents
paying for college you got inheritance
that is incredible but sometimes it's
like like you said you've never had a
budget yet you've never had to pay for
real things yet and I would love love
for you to get that experience just that
real life I'm using my income to make my
life Go Round And then we can start
talking about what it might look like to
invest in some real estate paying cash
for it
okay Simon the other piece of the
equation is the 10-year rule on that
inherited IRA does it apply in your
situation have you looked into that it's
a good point um
so I'm pretty sure is what what happened
was I got it about I'd say six years ago
and the the rule with it was
um is I could legally inherit it after
um 18 years of age so I'm 20. so I as
soon as I turned 18 I changed it from a
custodial account to to my own because
my mom's name was on it and now it's all
in my name and uh I talked to my advisor
and I'm pretty sure I can just take it
out but there's no required like 10 per
year for 10 years type deal no no no
okay I'd get some real firm answers on
that and do some homework and digging
and I'd also get a tax Pro in your
corner as you begin to do this thing
because you are so far ahead of the
curve and I love that you're trying to
go hey I want to manage this whale I
want to be a good Steward of this what I
don't want you to do is get so hung up
on this idea of like I gotta have cash
flow bro like that's all you see on
social media it's all about cash flow
and uh I don't want you to look up 50
years from now and have regret threats
because it wasn't all about cash flow
and you had to also live your life and
you want to start a family and buy a
house and not have all this risk going
on and so there's nothing wrong with
just investing I think you're going to
be a Real Estate Mogul at this point
yeah but why don't you do it the right
way do it with cash I don't know that's
so counter-cultural Jay to even say that
out loud like bro you want to push down
as little as possible and then you get
the HELOC and then you refi you know the
Burr method and I'm like stop listening
to guys on steroids who have red faces
tell you all about the real estate hacks
listen to pale guys who just live what
about me George well Jade uh I'm you're
not out there yet pale red face
[Music]
anyone that doesn't look like Joe
Rogan's angry telling you about real
estate that's who you should listen to
oh man that doesn't for this hour of the
show man when it comes to your life and
money you can tell me that you won't do
it but don't dare tell me that you can't
without with Christ all things are
possible
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign